si les médias la reine de las vegas
quittera la ville du jeu au sommet de
son art selon son ami stéphane laporte
qui l'a vu en concert deux fois la
semaine passée c'est les neurones forme
resteront sens d'ailleurs me dis
qu'après après ces spectacles s'entraîne
donc c'est vraiment une heure qu il est
là parce que ça fait quand même un long
jeu tout deux dans la presse au centre
informent
c'est en 2003 que céline dion et rené
angélil se sont lancés dans l'aventuré
las vegas
[Musique]
le pari était risqué à l'époque on avait
bâti le colosseum du caesars palace au
coût de 145 millions de dollars et pour
payer tout ça il fallait vendre 4000
billets pour chaque concert claude lemay
alias mégots se souvient très bien des
débuts ça a pris je dirais un an qu'on
s'aperçoive que ça marchait vraiment les
salles étaient pleines tout le temps
semblait qu'elle québec prenait le code
road des lieux de la ville oui céline
dion a pris le contrôle de la ville en
16 ans elle aura donné 1141 concert
devant plus de quatre millions cinq cent
mille spectateurs revenus générés 875
millions de dollars
imaginez-vous l'impact sur les autels
l'impact sur les restaurants sur les
choses que les gens les souvenirs que
les gens achètent sur le transport sur
l' aéroport sur les vols
alors c'est un espace est énorme elle
était un véhicule économique très
important car le foot dans ses liens
avec dieu sait quelle drôle d'idée et
maintenant lady gaga veut faire ça le
fait
pendant toute cette période las vegas a
aussi été le grand terrain de jeux du
cirque du soleil
son co fondateur guy laliberté salue la
fin de la résidence de la chanteuse
québécoise signe à la réalisation du
programme québécois à paris nous on a
contrôlé probablement la majorité des
rangs de billets alain totalement à las
vegas depuis les 15 20 dernières années
[Musique]
ce nouveau chapitre dans la carrière de
céline dion arrive au bon moment selon
son ami gago je viens de parler de
céline à l'instant ses débuts il ya
quelques semaines à mon instinct à paris
puis
ce qui est sûr un autre lancer
complètement qui s'amusent plus
tellement heureux pour elle mais quelle
carrière elle a tellement donné
sur sa page facebook la chanteuse a
écrit je cite la ventura las vegas a été
vraiment une affaire de famille
les souvenirs resteront pour toujours
photos à l'appui
elle montre qu'une importante partie de
sa vie avec rené angélil s'est déroulée
dans cette ville qu'elle a fait sienne
et avait un bel esprit très bel esprit
c'était très agréable et la vie la vie
était douce avec ce très douce moi je
suis certain c'est le rapport avec les
clés de la ville c'est sûr que à voir
venir avec des singes ou parce qu'il ya
quelqu'un m'a dit que vont ils faire une
offre que pourra pas refuser là parce
que c est l es tellement c'est ma grande
attraction a vécu ce que ce qu'un jour
ils vont ils de retour après tous ces
spectacles à las vegas céline dion
passera l'été au québec avant d'entamer
une tournée mondiale à l'automne
et de lancer un nouveau disque ici louis
fait depuis mai
radio canada las vegas
[Applaudissements]